Candice marques and Cheryl Lowe are
sisters who witnessed the shooting their
bosses were shot and are currently in
the hospital
Cheryl Candice good morning thank you
both for joining us after all that
you've been through good morning good
morning Cheryl have you you have any
update on how your bosses are doing
there there they were out of surgery as
of midnight tonight they are stable her
husband is in critical condition she's
in stable condition right now he was
shot three times and she was shot once
Candice as is so often the case with
shootings like this at first people
think it might be firecrackers and then
of course it's not at what point did you
realize this wasn't firecrackers and
what was it that that let you know this
was something very different as soon as
we stepped out of the porta potties we
turned in I saw a guy with a
high-powered rifle and he was putting
his clip in and I knew right there I
would thought a minute because he it
looked like he was pointing at the hoods
but he was trying to put something in it
and I was like wait no that's a gun and
I said we have to run though he was
targeting your tent specifically no no
that was anybody it was random he shot
one shot is going and then he'd put the
clip in and he just started moving back
and forth walking towards our tent
because that's where most of the people
were in that area and he just started
shooting police are reportedly looking
for a second suspect did you see an
another potential shooter there I only
seen the one we did not see the one oh
we only saw one a few people that were
in our area said that they did see a
second one but we did not see a second
one we only saw the one Cheryl we
understand your granddaughter just ten
years old was in the tent with you at
the time of the shooting how is she
doing this morning she was in the tent
with my with my boss's three-year-old
son that the ones that got shot she was
in the tent with him she actually did
see the shooter and she grabbed the
little boy and they hit underneath the
boxes underneath the table and she
seemed
to be doing okay you know this this
festivals a hero she certainly is she
certainly is this festival is known to
so many people it is a beloved
institution what do you want people to
know about the community of Gilroy you
know we don't want people to be scared
to go to festivals because you know it's
a random thing and we know what you know
gory we've seen people come together you
know and help other people you know that
they didn't know that's exactly what
happened tonight today everybody came
together as a group that was back behind
there trying to save everybody else's
life and and people were running it for
their lives it was not it was it was it
was like mass chaos but organized cast
everybody was helping everybody to be
safe Candice Marquez Cheryl lo thank you
both for joining us and our and our very
best of the families of your bosses we
wish everybody well thank you very much